clark kent 2.0 d money what's up bro
you had my back from the beginning dude
bro you had my back from there i walked
up to you like five minutes i know
before that all happened and i know why
are you so calm you're just strangely
calm and how you feeling i know and you
seem confident
yeah what's going through your mind
right now uh
i don't i don't know if my mouth can
keep up with what's going on in my mind
because my mind's like
but it's also like
kind of like shutting down so like
i i think that like this has been the
strangest thing to process you know it's
like you hear the thing like this is
what i was hoping for this is what i was
praying for
wait what's happening and it's like you
just feel everything in you every
emotion you've ever felt like flooding
at the same time
but um it's insane man like literally
you know i'm i'm a nine-year-old boy
dreaming of
of chasing the things that i love
falling in love with magic and and here
i am years later like standing on the
stage and hearing my name called as the
winner of this show it's just it's it's
it's crazy it's more than i could have
ever asked for a dream though i'll tell
you what it is
it's magic it's magic dude
magic superman listen i know i've had
your back since the beginning yeah back
to the end even when you go to vegas
thank you bro holler at your boy if you
need somebody to bring you out on this
okay dude i know i'm here for you man
dude i do it a little shameless plug and
i love it because i would hire you a
heartbeat let's do it you're going to be
like i'm going to teach you magic i'm
going to come out in a superman costume
let's do it dude let's do it bro we'll
call david copperfield and find out how
to make people fly because he knows i
don't know i don't know how to do that
because you know you know i might know
you can't tell us right now because
we're rolling cameras i know you know
how to make people fly don't play with
me i'm coming to your vegas shop i'll be
the first ticket trust me bro you got
vip dude you don't got to buy a ticket i
got you what did the judges say to you
no idea i have no idea no idea i have no
clue
to them i don't know either
no i'm being serious no one's asked me
that yet and i really don't know what
would you say to them right now if you
could put a a thought together what do
you say to those judges i was critiques
and all that yes i would say thank you
to all the judges for every
word of encouragement they've spoken
over me i've held all these words like
so close to my heart especially um i
don't remember which round it was but
heidi told me she said just keep doing
you keep doing you just be yourself and
um i mean it was the greatest thing it's
so easy to compare so many other people
that i love people who have inspired the
world people who have performed
incredible magic and um i feel like i
had permission to be myself you know and
i and i did and i'm just so incredibly
grateful for that so all the judges
thank you simon cowell thank you for
making the show i feel like simon cowell
had this dream come true to make other
people's dreams come true and i get to
be a part of that the 16th person to be
a part of that on this show
so yeah it's it's absolutely crazy it's
gigantic it's gigantic man that's a good
word it's gigantic who'd you call did
you call the wife already called the
wife well how'd that conversation go
didn't pick up at first dealing with our
boys
throwing fits about to go to bed listen
hold on shout out to the moms shout out
to the moms i know dealing with it like
like we've been dreaming of this for so
long all my wife wanted to hear is that
her husband won america's got talent and
she didn't pick up because she's taking
care of our boys that is commitment and
that is love and i eventually got to
talk to her because i called my mom who
was with her so then my mom was like
here he's trying to talk to you so yeah
it's it was yeah she's she's an
incredible mother incredible wife and
i'm i'm not here because i'm by myself
that's for sure they have been behind me
100 this whole time listen
your husband won america's got talent i
just want to get this sentence it feels
weird hearing you say it because i'm
still like it just feels like i'm like
hearing someone say that i want
america's got talent is weird
it's weird this is still dustin
you won
america's got talent i know they're
gonna embark on a vegas career you told
me your lease ran out in virginia today
today yesterday yup today what are you
gonna do with that million dollars that
didn't exist in your life yes well we're
gonna definitely get a u-haul
to put our stuff wherever it's going
because i don't know um it's crazy
because we know change is coming
obviously we're moving it's just it's
weird having no idea like what this is
gonna unfold the timeline of these
things you don't mean ending up in vegas
and so um right now thankful uh well
actually shout out to my parents who we
say we don't know where we're going can
we come in the basement for a little
while so
we're driving to my parents and then
we're going to figure it out from there
i love it i love it oh my goodness um
this is the question now that i get to
ask you that i've asked so many of the
other people that have come back from
the previous seasons yeah what advice do
you have for contestants trying to come
in to the next season yeah um i would
say two things one
so many people have been telling me this
through this whole process and um i feel
like the icing on the cake was heidi
told me it from
well i don't remember which round it was
but she just said keep doing you keep
being yourself and for me i think that's
been so huge because
it's easy to try and want to
be like the people that i look up to and
feel like i have to measure up to
something and i feel like when we keep
trying to measure up to be someone else
we don't we don't find our own full
potential and so um the first thing i
would say to people is just to be you
find out what you love find out what
you're good at and if people don't like
it that's that's fine at least you're
doing what you love and you're going to
enjoy doing what you love more than you
enjoy trying to be somebody else um and
then the second thing
i would say is just just to keep going
not give up you know this is not my
first season auditioning for america's
got talent i um i had auditioned
previous seasons multiple times and it
was just no no no and now you know
you're happy which is just
crazy still saying this dustin yeah i'm
gonna say one more time you won
america's guts just so you know in case
you forgot
oh my gosh it's all it's funny you're
saying that because all the judges that
came through i said what advice do you
have for dustin as he embarks on this
journey and they all said i have no
advice for him he needs to keep doing
him and just never get comfortable
that's amazing man stay hungry for it i
mean how much was was sophia's tv son
rico a good luck charm tonight dude i
know bro like seeing this guy come i
mean he's someone who's been
accomplishing his dreams right getting
to be on television do all this stuff
and so having him up there was cool matt
franco getting to be up there another
magician who's won america's got talent
um dude these guys were celebrating yeah
with us back here when they called your
name they were jumping up and down
insane bro i know i'm like i'm beyond
honored i'm i'm humbled i'm great i
every every good emotion i could feel
right now bro is is is is in my heart
and it's crazy it feels amazing tell me
about your instagram dms what are they
looking like right now you got all sorts
of weird people celebrities jumping in
and thumbs up and you what's going on in
there you know i'm uh
i'm not like so much of a social media
guy so i have no idea i'll probably
check to see hey what's happening but um
yeah i don't know that's a great
question i should probably look i mean
it's probably pretty wild in there at
this point
i know man it's crazy i know i probably
i probably will um
your sons do you think do you think they
even understand right now anything other
than all they understand is i'm getting
more attention than them and so they
need to do everything possible to make
sure all eyes are back on them but it's
fine they're toddlers every once in a
while maybe you can let you know let me
let me get a little bit of attention but
you know it's it's about them right now
so it's fine it's fine that's what we
committed to when we became parents
dustin
yes
you
won america's got
talent and you deserve it and you're
you're it's so it's so honest and pure
and authentic who you are right now and
i feel so lucky to have been on this
this small journey
i'm so blessed man you've been so
incredibly encouraging from day one so
guys this dude right here he's a hero
he's amazing seriously it's people like
you who've helped me to continue to
believe in myself and to be here dude
you've known me like what a couple weeks
now and people like you that inspire me
and these people watching to get up
change their lives and take that chance
yeah thank you dude
thank you thank you man thank you guys
thank you all love brother i appreciate
you so much
[Music]
you